[Music]
Godzilla in the monsterverse has never
stayed the same he has always changed
every time he appears on screen the only
time he remains somewhat similar is
between king of the monsters and in GVK
and yet even in the last movie Godzilla
versus Kong he seems to be more
irradiated than in kotm Godzilla's ever
evolving nature is isn't actually new in
fact there has never been a Godzilla
that stayed the same in design even the
showa and hyay Designs differ slightly
from one movie to another hell even his
Origins tell us of a mutation or an
evolving element intrinsic to the Gman
this theme was followed in more recent
Millennium movies in the anime in Shin
Godzilla and single point so Godzilla
here in the monsterverse is basically
sticking to the source material
otherwise by not changing he would
divert from it okay now this video will
describe all the five times Godzilla
evolved in the monsterverse why and how
as
well the first evolution so from what to
what right okay so the base form here is
the 1954 Godzilla that actually appeared
just a few days back in Monarch the
legacy of monsters that new series and
the evolved form is the 2014 OG design
the first monsterverse Godzilla form
that we saw on the big screen the 195 4
and 2014 were very similar with only
body height belly roundness and dorsal
plate size that is different so Godzilla
was struck by The Castle Bravo nuclear
bomb in the bikini atols and because of
it he was forced to absorb a tremendous
amount of radiation which not just
damaged his body but also filled it with
a momentous amount of energy so due to
this he grew from 300 ft or 90 M to 355
ft or 108 M his dorsal plates grew big
as well even relative to his size and
his belly got round so that's the first
evolution we can infer for the Gman in
the monsterverse there might be prior
ones but since there is no Visual
Evidence there is no crime the First
Transformation was a reaction to the
bomb evolving to be able to Bear a
future nuclear blast and absorb the
radiation the second evolution so this
is the most known one though the Chang
from Godzilla 2014 to Godzilla 2019 or
the king of the monsters bomb here the
cause is due to a death battle with the
muto Prime which is an ancient parasitic
enemy species who was known to have
killed at least two more individuals of
the goira species in the past in the
battle Godzilla was initially outmatched
and his straight jaged Dole plates was
shattered by the Sonic Screech of the
muto thankfully with the aid of Emma
Russell somehow he got a grip on the
distracted Prime and defeated it with a
nuclear pulse from his destroyed plates
and also stomping his head later on so
after the battle godzill went into
recovery mode and for almost a year he
disappeared only to reappear in 2015 in
the legacy of monsters with a larger
size and a more Maple Leaf shaped row of
dorsal plates as to why these changes
came to be well he had to grow bigger to
be able to take on another mut Prime if
the time comes and a differently shaped
plates were to counter the Resonance of
the Sonic Screech of the mut Prime and
also the largest sizes comes with a
greater capacity for atomic energy star
and output in the form of a more
powerful and more intense Atomic breath
heat ray the third evolution a temporary
one so this one right here is stated to
be a temporary Evolution or a
transformation but still is one
nonetheless here Godzilla even with the
evolved kotm form was unable to best
Monster Zero in a fight on land and
after the tree haded Dragon Got Juice up
with electricity from the power grid he
was done for there was also a couple of
factors that actually forced his
Evolution one was the nuclear bomb that
s zawa detonated in his layer when he
was recovering and unlike the Castle
Bravo nuke which was in the open air
meaning a lot of the energy and
radiation was wasted uh everywhere here
the nuke was blasted in a confined space
and therefore there was more reflection
and being stuck in the same place so
more substantial radiation was absorbed
by the body of Godzilla which made him
overload it with it to a point of coming
to melting down but thankfully mothra's
life Essence here which is a unique
symbiosis with Godzilla allowed the Big
G's body to actually evolve into a
burning form which could unleash a set
of nuclear pulses that not only burnt
off the body of Monster Zero but also
released the excess radiation that would
have otherwise been fatal to
Godzilla the fourth Evolution this is a
small minor Evolution and it is from the
king of the monsters Godzilla form to
the Godzilla versus K GVK Godzilla form
and what are the actual changes well
Godzilla had the same height of 120 M or
393 fet the same weight but there's a
stark difference in the way his entire
body glowed with atomic energy and also
his dorsal place was slightly larger not
that really noticeable to the lay man
but to us we could see it so even though
he was able to show intimidation
displays in kotm why was he glowing more
in GVK than in the previous movie well
the actual reason is that it is maybe
due to the after effects of Mo's life
Essence that allowed him to survive the
burning form therefore teaching his G
cells to be able to handle more atomic
energy both absorbing and outputting it
it is also a reaction to his fight with
gidora which showed that he wasn't as
fast as he needed to be and that his
Atomic breath wasn't up to the mark thus
as we saw in GVK Godzilla was more
brutal in fighting had more stamina more
speed and definitely more agile and also
had a very very powerful Atomic breath
that was able to burn right through the
Earth to the center to the hollow Earth
the fifth Evolution and now this final
evolution the pinkzilla form so here in
gxk Godzilla an Kong the new Empire he
will change from the well-known GVK blue
to a magenta based color pattern with
respect to the energy glow if one looks
at the electromagnetic spectrum the pink
Violet magenta coloration has a way
higher frequency and energy output than
the blue Spectrum that's one thing the
next is his dorsal plates they will mold
and grow to become some sort of Crystal
amethyst spikes he will also lose belly
fat he will just lose it all uh grow
longer arms and legs and have a spike at
the end of the tail a set of spikes so
what could be the driving Factor through
this transformation this drastic
evolutionary leap well the pink magenta
Atomic breath would be a reaction to the
proton scream which bore more power than
the blue Atomic breath and I think this
new one will generate way more energy it
will beat the previous one of the Mecha
Godzilla his new skin texture will also
be a response to the proton scream
burning his chest in GVK with respect to
his other physical changes they are all
in response to godz being outmatched in
the fight against Mecha Godzilla in Hong
Kong so now with longer arms just like
Mecha Godzilla longer legs just like
Mecha Godzilla Spike at the tail spikes
uh somewhat similar to mea Godzilla
drill at at the end of the tail he will
be a match or even be superior to Mecha
Godzilla hell even Kong was trying to
keep up with Godzilla in running so that
shows he has increased in speed to a
great extent so let's take a look at the
different forms of radiation for
evolution of Godzilla and these are as
follows the first one was thermonuclear
in the form of the Castle Bravo test the
second was geothermal radiation from his
layer third and fourth thermonuclear and
Mo's life Essence the fifth evolution is
going to be powered by The Hollow Earth
power source a ping radiation a unique
one different from the one scen in GVK
so that's all about the evolutionary
changes of Godzilla and what he has went
through in the monsterverse from 1954
till gxk now if you like this video then
watch this other one as well and you do
check out our Channel as we might have
things that you haven't seen before like
subscribe and we'll see you in the next
one take care fam